hey guys and welcome to layer inspired
powered by icon plus and sponsored by
cake wallet great to have all of you
here so since this is powered by icon
plus we're going to do a really quick
icon news announcement so very exciting
physical ids
may become a thing of the past in south
korea as the icon network
this month are launching the first
government-backed blockchain based id
called my id so very exciting so without
further ado we have a very good friend
of mine somebody who has been
super generous and super helpful to me
in the space and somebody who's buying a
ridiculous amount of bitcoin every
single week if you have a guest we are
joined
with jason williams jason how are you
doing today
what's going on leia it's good to have
you
how are you doing it's good to be here
look i'll tell you the production
quality of what i just saw uh was uh
it put going parabolic to shame so we've
got we've got to step up our game
obviously
because this i love it yeah nice job
nice job
thank you thank you speaking of i think
i've actually forgotten to hit a light
on so let me just hit this on
is that better is that do you think that
looks even more professional i'm telling
you
it you couldn't do anything more at this
point you couldn't do anything wrong
you got to check out so i i know that
one of your stipulations
uh for me coming on was i wasn't allowed
to uh bag on any coins we're not
using the word coin on this show
you just said no okay okay from here
onwards no more
crap coins but you know i i was reading
recently and you got to check this out
there is a retainer that uh
in your mouth it's a retainer an
impression
that's being used for biometric
identification
on computers now and to get into doors
so you've got to check this out
i was it's a new technology and it it
it reads the rugay at the top of your
mouth which are like a fingerprint
yeah you put the retainer in it opens
doors opens your computer
it identifies you biometrically i'm
uncomfortable with that immediately
really because i think it's going to
create a whole world of lispy
protection i mean think about it it's
all this
like lispy safety
just right right consider it uh all
right
i'm gonna look it up i'm thinking about
investing but we'll see
speaking of investing so you
um are buying a ridiculous amount of
bitcoin every single week i think i've
seen like hundreds of thousands
um that's insane so for people that
don't know you
firstly who is jason williams and how
the hell are you buying so much bitcoin
every single week
yeah so um my background super quick
healthcare uh was licensed as a
physician assistant
got accepted to yale i ended up dropping
out of yale
to start a medical company called fast
med
i was probably 25. built that into the
nation's second largest urgent care and
primary care
private practice in the whole country i
had 400 employees
about 400 doctors and pas working for me
127 locations across the country
took it through a number of private
equity exits the first in 2010
another one in 2012 and then sold the
whole company
in 2015 for around 500 million bucks
so 500 million numbers only people could
dream of let's just like let's just not
like be so
uh nonchalant about it 500 million right
keep going
so so i went from being like a guy in a
lab coat
to an administrator in a suit and tie
to what you see today which is kind of
my true self it's a relaxed person
i've been afforded a tremendous
opportunity to manage
our family money at this point i'm also
participating in managing other people's
money with morgan creek digital we'll
get into that probably
but yeah it was it was an amazing
journey for a poor kid
growing up in a single family in queens
new york
immigrants uh immigrant family and um
you know i'm kind of like the uh i would
i feel like a typical a typical
uh sequoyah-backed investment
immigrant um founder
interesting now this is actually why i
wanted you on the show because for those
that don't know jason and i
um we have i would say um this same kind
of perspective the same kind of like
want for the world so we both want to
have a positive impact we want to help
people
but i believe in some ways we kind of
have a different way of doing that right
so the reason i want to get you one is
because like you said you came from a
poor background
and you mentioned to me a couple of
times your dad wasn't necessarily
present when you were growing up
and yet you've been able to become a
billionaire millionaire i'm probably
i mean i'm probably worth 130 million
okay right and that's all from my poor
background fatherless
um that is insane right and i think one
of the biggest things that people keep
talking about in society
is how the issue is we're seeing a lack
of fathers and that is creating
bad behavior you know that's you know a
lot of men that are in jail
a lot of times we often find that
they're fatherless they've had bad
relationships with their fathers so
i want to understand how you were able
to essentially
pull yourself up from that kind of
situation because
what we talk about and see a lot now is
that people sort of say
i've come from a crappy background i've
had you know i haven't been born with a
silver spoon in my mouth i've come
you know i'm a victim i've had this i've
had that i'm this i'm that
um and yet you've been able to sort of
overcome that and for me that just
really fits in line with
my ideologies um my belief in everything
that i love
so talk to me about how you're able to
raise yourself up basically
yeah so um we'll start off on the
probably exact same page that we
both believe in high levels of personal
accountability right
yeah all right um and that's a good
thing and i i
i would say that's fundamental to this
discussion
you know from from what happened to me
you know my mother
uh is sicilian and my father is from
manchester england but
of jamaican descent uh his father
owned a large farm in manchester jamaica
if you can manchester parish jamaica so
a lot of manchester united
that's pretty wild right so you try to
attract that so
they met in new york um i came into the
picture
they got married and then got divorced
so my dad was out of the picture when i
was first born
and then my mother was a hairdresser and
that that was it so she worked as a
hairdresser
and um we
i grew up in a single family home my
mother uh
dated some people seriously so i had
some influence of
of some men in my life but they weren't
great
so i don't want to dive too much into
the weeds here just to paint the
perspective
she she dated a um a police officer
a correctional officer from rankers
island rikers islands uh
is a uh i would say like a
high high max or super max uh
very dangerous place in new york yeah
where criminals are capped
this guy was um he was kind of a bad guy
alcoholic and verbally abusive to my mom
so
gosh yeah you think about
you're already and you know we'll go
over some of the statistics this is a
super heavy discussion
um but um you know you you put a kid in
an environment like that
you you may say he's a bit disadvantaged
because of the single family thing
my mother loved me very much she was
doing the best that she could
she kind of attracted some bad
uh bad choices and and partners so i was
subjected to that
so you know i i grew up
in a in an environment that was kind of
hostile super
um super unstable and
how did i transcend that exactly
well leia i don't know i'm sure that
it's caused
it's caused some issues and because i i
can't imagine a child
growing up in that environment and not
coming out of it
with uh you know being molded um
differently than say and i don't know
your background but
i mean what was your kind of experience
growing up as a child and then maybe i
can synthesize
a final thought on that i mean yeah for
sure i'm happy to yeah let's do it
let's get deep um but before i do i just
also want to thank i think it's um ron
nelson
who um told everybody he gave you like
he told everyone to come follow and
everything so that's super sweet say
thank you ron
um so for me um luckily enough um i am
privileged in that i have parent
privilege which i think is one of the
most powerful privileges there is
um so thank god um i've been born with
two fantastic parents have always
um done their best put me first um
you know and they've sort of sacrificed
everything they needed to give me
um what i will say is um because then i
sort of
you know sort of a bad thing these days
to be privileged right to be born
privileged you should feel
some sort of guilt um i you know and i
think that's sort of hard to sort of
get rid of um but for me what i was
saying i sort of tweeted a little bit
about this recently
um despite having such a great sort of
background
i have my own personal struggles so i
suffered with three chronic illnesses
before
the age of 20. um so that has impacted
me
in other ways um but actually i would
say in positive ways
because i learned how i needed to like
i'm gonna i shouldn't swear but whatever
i said you know i've got to get my
together and sort of really
like nobody's gonna get me better but me
um you know i went to a load of
different doctors and this and that and
nobody was going to help but me so
for me that's where my sort of like
power comes from
so a little bit different but both the
struggle i would say
yeah no look that that that is the
common theme like from
from my perspective all of that hardship
all of that um struggle
going without economic instability
moving a bunch of times being around
other poor folks
growing up in that environment i just
learned
what i didn't want to be what i didn't
want to do what i didn't want to
participate in the kind of person i
didn't want to be i didn't want to be
some hustler or you know i just
it just showed me everything
uh that um that i didn't want to be
now here's the problem when you don't
have access to
successful people successful mentors uh
people who
who can show you other options you you
may have a desire for something more but
you don't know how to get there
and a lot of times the the path is not
as hard as you think
it's really um it's really just who you
know
and um and little course corrections and
decisions
for me um i just wanted to become a
doctor because i thought that was
that would give me the education it
would
lead me out of this kind of economically
depressed
situation i was in and um you know i
just shot for that leia
yeah and i want to jump in because i've
been speaking a lot recently to people
about where motivation comes from right
and that's the whole point of this
podcast
and i think people often go through
adversity and
in that adversity they sort of get very
upset
and worn down and they play that sort of
victim idea
victimhood mentality but i think you
have to use that adversity
to say actually i don't want that use
that as an opportunity which is exactly
what you did you said you know you
um i saw where i came from i saw the
lack of you know i saw that economic um
uncertainty and lack of stability and
you use
that to say actually i don't want that
you were sort of shown what you don't
want
yeah i mean it could have i don't mean
to interrupt you but you know when you
see
people abusing drugs abusing alcohol
being verbally abusive physical abuse
you can either participate in that you
know you can have some predisposition
you can buy into the fact that um
because my dad's an alcoholic i have to
be an alcoholic
you know or you can say boy there's a
lot of alcoholism in my family
maybe i shouldn't binge drink or
participate
in in that behavior again i tend to try
to control the things that i can
you know life is short and life moves
very fast
and if you can try to control some of
the variables do it
you know i was reading recently and i
think this may be
interesting the impact of divorce
on kids you know again i'm a product of
a divorced
uh of a divorce family and i think in
the united states
we have one of the largest populations
of single parent
uh of children under 18 being raised by
single parents
i think next in line is the uk actually
oh really
i'm not surprised this is the westward
so you you see it
um and then russia then france um
ireland and then when you get uh to asia
it's japan and india has a very low
uh low percentage of of people uh under
18 years of age raised by a single
parent um i think i think
the way that we do divorce in the united
states
is equally as devastating as all the
things that i've lifted up to you so
i've said
you know physical abuse mental abuse
substance abuse
all of those verbal abuse and then the
divorce
i think needs to be explored because
the way attorneys use uh divorce
to extract any kind of economics from
that family
pit the parents against each other the
child is
is left as a victim is is cruel and it's
wrong
um i've ran into yeah yeah we're good
i'll just say i kind of want to pick up
on that because i think that's a major
issue
um in western society and also when we
talk about like the importance of
fathers and so
on and you often find that a lot of
times and i'm going to call this
female privilege is that you know a
woman can
cheat on her husband a woman can do all
sorts of terrible things be an unfit
mother actually not an unfit mother but
she can cheat on her husband
um you go to court and you often find
that she gets half the money
she gets the house and a lot of times
he's just left and you often find that
really does
sort of put men off marriage
um which again isn't very good for
western society but
i want to focus more also just like on
how you were able to pull yourself up
out of this situation and
what tips you would give to people who
may feel okay you know i come from a bad
background i don't know where to start i
don't have any mentors
people that really feel right now that
they are in that sort of
victimhood mentality they're struggling
to get out of it what would you say as
an
absolute self-made millionaire um don't
say buy bitcoin
but tell me what you would say to sort
of help them pick themselves up what
tips did you get
look i can i can identify it
specifically
when i was 16 years old i was bagging
groceries at a grocery store
called publix and i walked the groceries
out to
a woman's car and the woman said to me
you look like a nice young man
what do you plan to do with your life
and i just threw out like
i'm gonna become a doctor and she said
to me
one of the most impactful things uh that
probably changed the trajectory of my
life she said what are you willing to do
to become a doctor
and i i stepped back a second and said
all right
i'm hanging out with a bunch of uh of
people that are probably going to clean
pools and become
construction workers and there's nothing
wrong with that they're
no one's going to go to college that i'm
hanging out with because they don't care
about that
and i'm and i'm pretending that i want
to be a doctor
so let's get my stuff together i didn't
say the s word
and and i went out and found a mentor
and it was a man called
randall seeger he was a urologist in
port st
lucie florida and he became my mentor
from the time i was 16 until i graduated
my undergrad
uh so every summer i spent with dr
seger shadowing him in the office doing
administrative stuff
at first until he uh
he really saw i was serious he would
bring me in the room with patients
let me scrub into surgery with him and
watch i mean i
really came into it during that it was
literally
i went out and found my mentor i didn't
wait for it to come to me
and i certainly didn't look around the
house looking for
you didn't wait for the government to
give you a mentor no
no yeah and i think that's really
important and well i think mentors
are essential right because if you can
put somebody on a pedestal
and sort of look up to them and sort of
say how are they navigating how are they
doing things what did they do
i think that's really helpful and i
think that's something which for me
personally i sort of
need to do maybe a little bit better but
i was watching
um i think maybe it was seth godin um
i don't if you know of seth godin so
he's just an absolute genius and i was
watching something that he said
and he said people don't understand
about mentors right
you think that you need a physical
mentor so this is for people who are
like okay maybe i need a mentor but how
do i get one
you actually don't need a physical
mentor to be there you don't need to
know them personally
but what you can do is see somebody
online and watch what they do from a
distance see how they navigate
understand
how they um sort of go through life and
also you can look at their history what
they've done
it's so simple to have that mental from
a distance because i appreciate you know
some you know maybe you're busy and i
know we spoke earlier and you said
you're crazy busy so
you're not going to want to mentor
everybody not everybody so i think it's
so important to be able to look at
people from afar that you admire
and see what the hell they do copy them
it's so simple
that's right and then dr seger was like
the epitome of health
he tried to have a good family he ran
his business
he read uh passionately
he was he was a great communicator he
was a leader in his space
you know he had the trophies he had the
things that
i saw as important um and
things i wanted in my own life so i i
got the road map
it wasn't hard it just took discipline
and um i was already hungry leia so uh
from there
that was easy you know it was just like
go at it with reckless abandon
try to do the right thing i'm not
perfect i made lots of mistakes along
the way
and um and then don't let all that
baggage hold you back like i don't sit
here today
in any way and feel sad that i have
just my mom or maybe not a great
relationship with this person or
you know they had all this physical and
social whatever
things going on it doesn't matter like
it doesn't matter
if anything it's like these these
cornerstones
to the foundation that make me who i am
yeah it's true and you just have to open
up your mind right and understand that
anything is actually possible
and i think you make a really
interesting point because you are hungry
and i think that's
often um we kind of touched on this
where the motivation comes from it's
sort of when you see a glimpse of maybe
what you want or you've seen a huge
um sort of window into what you don't
want and that's where it comes from
but i i want to talk about where the
government has a part to playing this
because i believe that's where you and i
tend to differ um so i look at you as
somebody that is totally
self-made the self-made billionaire that
comes from a difficult background
um where so whereas you would so i would
sort of encourage people to do
more of that whereas you would sort of
say the government needs to sort of step
in more
well um you know this is a tough
this is a tough situation um
i think that social programs are
important
um and can be a a kind of a
jump start to some of the things that
we're discussing today
because i i don't want to to say that
in any way that i'm self-made like
i am self-driven right i define who i
am but the community around me and these
mentors
because beyond dr seeger like i can go
through this progression because once i
found
like the mentor i needed at that time
that's not the mentor i needed the next
stage of my life right yeah it went dr
seger from 16
to 20 and then from 20 on
was this man mike saffley and then from
to about 30 was another physician robert
ferguson
and then beyond that was a phd
psychologist named
richard lazar and these men
in my life helped me progress
and think about things the way i do and
have
shared their life experience with me and
they were so different
dr lazar worked for bill clinton he's
jewish
his kids uh his kids were in israel
he shared with me wonderful lessons that
were so different than growing up in a
catholic family
with a sicilian mother and
anyway it it was all important
so you've got to be on the hunt all the
time yes
the right mentor at the right time it
was a community
yeah agreed and i think community is so
important and even let's just keep like
talk about this on a really small scale
even for me on crypto in crypto twitter
let's just say right
i've managed to find some really
fantastic people including yourself
that have this you know show me so much
kindness and so much support and so much
help and you know
absolutely appreciate that right but
that's about me being an individual
and putting myself forward um number one
being driven putting myself forward and
number three
um being a nice enough and approachable
person to speak to you speak to other
people that have been super helpful
right
and that is on me now
that is more than the government could
ever do right
so what i'm trying to what i'm trying to
differentiate here is people often just
sort of i'm gonna say they sort of sit
on their ass and sort of
expect for it to come to them the
government owes me more they owe me this
they owe me that i can't do this because
of this or i need that or
whatever but i think it's not
it's not essentially the case number one
in my opinion which is just my opinion i
don't think the government owes you
anything
um but i think that you make more of an
impact
than the government could ever do for
you right so
everything that i've done and everything
that you have done
is because you were driven you saw okay
i had that
that sort of light bulb moment when you
were when you met that woman she's you
know you're doing groceries she said
you said i want to be a doctor you had
your mentors you had you know
this is all you and you were able to do
it
what did the government do for you well
the government gave me loans to go to
college the
you know i got pell grants stafford
loans scholarships there was no way i
could have paid for college
beyond that when i interviewed at yale
they said no one
is denied admission to yale because they
can't afford it because that was the
question i had like
i i was accepted uh but during my um
during that interview process i said
look i definitely don't have the money
to go here
you know i definitely don't you know my
master's degree from university of
nebraska same thing so
um what about sponsorships
what is your opinion on sponsorships
because you're obviously very
intelligent i'm sure you could have got
a sponsorship
now in the united states um it may be
defined something different
scholarships and sponsorships are
different tell me what a sponsorship is
so oh no i would call it a scholarship
sorry i apologize
no i think i think scholarships are
super important again
i could not have gone to school without
scholarships
uh loans uh pell grants stafford loans
all of that no way it would have worked
for me there was just no way
college is super expensive it's
ridiculous um
you know i was going to uh make one
other point
um because i i wanted to talk about um
this uh the um divorce thing
real quick yeah please go for it no no
i like to kind of caveat these
perspectives with books
so if your people are out there and they
get a chance you got to read
the cure for divorce culture by ashley
nicole
russell i read it recently and i thought
it was
really cool she's she's an attorney that
practices something called collaborative
divorce
so they kind of like end it like
breaking up a business
versus versus destroying each other
it's uh it's done by like arbitration so
i i'm i'm interested in that and i think
it's a uh it's kind of a european thing
you know i see a lot yeah i see a lot of
people breaking up
um like conscious decoupling
i
yeah conscious decoupling so anyway just
uh just check out that book but um
yeah the i i i'm interested to to really
get at why
why you're so opposed to um government
intervention
you know the uk is completely wrecked
like your gdp is
trash right now you know i spend a lot
of time talking about
the unemployment here in the united
states you know our current situation
um coming out of covet 19 but i think
you guys are in
like a worse situation than we are in
the u.s with unemployment
um and support around that why don't you
give me yeah i mean
yeah absolutely yeah so so in in the uk
right now i mean i think we've sort of
just said apparently came out in the
news yesterday we're going to the worst
recession that we've ever seen and this
is for several different reasons right
it's hugely due to coronavirus right
we've had a lot of our we've had a lot
of things closing down
businesses um going into liquidation and
so on so that's mainly due to the
coronavirus um
what i would say with regards to
um why i'm so much anti-government
intervention is because i have the
mentality of freedom right so i'm a
libertarian
and i would say that the government
doesn't owe you anything because it just
doesn't
right like the government we've seen the
government do terrible things
over centuries and my
idea is why are we suddenly trusting the
government now right
and you often find that when you give a
little they take a mile
so let's take the coronavirus situation
for a second i believe
that it's kind of concerning that we've
actually been able to police
and force people to stay at home right i
think that is hugely concerning because
once we do that
when do we not do that anymore and you
get and then now now that's now that's
the situation
now we're forcing people to wear masks
now i'm not going to get into
whether i believe masks work or not it's
not about that it's about the
forceful nature of it okay
because it's then like where do we then
draw that line we are now having people
talk about forcing people
to take a vaccination okay
this is forcing people to put a foreign
substance into their body
for me personally it's too much i'm an
individual and i
am suspicious of the government and as i
should be and as everybody should be
we've seen how they've behaved over
decades right i mean we've seen what
happened in world war ii
for me you know that's just
unthinkable basically so for me i often
find that you have to be incredibly
suspicious and i think also a lot of the
time you find that people
rely too much on the government right
it's sort of it disincentivizes you to
work hard when you have a social safety
net
sometimes it sort of it disincentivizes
you to do that and i think a lot of
government practices which we've spoken
about let's talk about minimum wage for
example
actually have an adverse effect these
socialist practices have adverse effects
we've spoken about minimum wage before
how it actually ostracizes the people
that it's supposed to help the most
i just find that the best thing to do as
we've spoken about
is community um we've spoken a lot about
apprenticeships i think they're really
important versus university
um you know what i would also love to
see is
private run businesses or sorry
private-run charities
like you know you get philanthropists
doing what they've got to do potentially
helping people get those grants to
university
and so on but you tend to have a very
different opinion
let's talk about because i i don't
necessarily disagree with anything you
said i just think there are nuances and
complexities
around those points that you know you
you should explore and be intellectually
curious about i mean
think about your nhs program you have
you have
nationalized healthcare and it's trash
it's no good apologies to any nhs
workers i think they do a great job
but it's run terribly but it's free
um uh directly yes not indirectly no
well i mean you're taxed for it
right but it's free indeed and i feel
paid for it indirectly
right and i i tend to agree with you
that sorry i'm going to jump in ace of
spades has just said nothing is free in
life and you know ace of spades you
right
and and i would say to you in
historically and in my opinion
the government is terrible at running
businesses
exactly right so the nhs
is taxed you pay for it through taxes
but it's a free service it's a social
safety net but it's a safety net because
you can only pay taxes if you make money
it's the same thing in the united states
don't you know what please let me jump
in let me jump in
you can go out and you can get trashed
right you can
drink you can get so trashed to the
point where you're throwing up on the
streets
you need that free ambulance to come and
save you
right what a waste of our services what
a waste of their time
and when you find that things are free
and you don't pay for it you don't care
about it
there are people that need like no no no
no faces
that's what happens people are doing you
know
majority but that's not the majority of
people that are using the nhs
oh yeah let me let me tell you it's a
good waste of our time
like british culture there's a lot of
drugs and there's a lot of drinking okay
that is huge here
and too many times do i know and have i
seen
ambulances having to come out and do
that now i
lived in the states for three months and
um i met a girl
and she's and i i was joking i was like
oh my god what if i drink too much i'm
underage you know
what if i end up throwing up and the
ambulance come and all this stuff and
she was like
the ambulance no that would never you
cost us
thousands and it's just that right which
switched something in my head
i was like i need to be more careful
because actually
i could have to pay a lot of money and
to just to get fixed right and i'm
telling you you go on the streets on a
night in
around the uk it is trash there's
drinking there's people peeing on the
streets
there's people throwing up on the
streets there's people paralytic and
that is because it doesn't matter the
free health service will come and save
you
interesting because that was going to be
my question so you're saying that
because it's
free or there isn't a charge there
there's a charge around the periphery
that people abuse the system absolutely
and i think
people would we would see less people
getting trashed and throwing up on our
streets
if they actually had to pay for the
ambulance to come get them i'll tell you
straight like i've had some of my
friends have been picked up in an
ambulance when we were younger when we
were around like 17 18
just for drinking too much at a party um
they wouldn't and
and these girls don't have money and
they would not be drinking so much
if they had to pay for that ambulance
what a waste of a service so leah
do you think that the world is moving
toward
nationalized health care or
fee-for-service health care private
health care like we have in the united
states
i think it's moving towards um private
health care
do you do you think that they'll you
think that the nhs will be disbanded and
it'll become a fee-for-service uh
project at some point so i i don't know
the ins and outs but i already know
that that's it it's being privatized and
that's like a massive
massive issue that we have in the uk and
you know
the nhs was created right i think it
would be impossible like i find it
like it would be nearly impossible to go
back
once you've once you've created once
you've created this social safety net
it's like impossible to move back in the
other direction
100 unless something happens right like
for example let's just take this whole
corona virus situation
um it would be what we are you know
getting everybody online
is very difficult you know my dad only
learned to use zoom
um and skype bless him just because he
had to right
and so i think we would have to have a
situation like
that whereby it forces you need a huge
catalyst to make this happen whether
it's some form of revolution somebody
comes into power that everybody hates
um you know you often find that when
there's dictatorships people go the
absolute
opposite way so i think i think it would
take time and we would have to see
um you know what happens with that um
but something that we do tend to agree
on is all of this
relates to crypto doesn't it i think
i think every thematic discussion
uh around all of this stuff um
is going to be eventually part of uh
this crypto world yeah with it without a
doubt
without that okay so so tell us what
people are screaming about the nhs in
the comments let's have a quick look
the nhs will never be privatized because
we have a law directly stopping that
at 49 yeah i mean it's a little tricky
one right now
yeah like um just to kind of put a stamp
on that
i actually see all the work that
politicians are doing here in the united
states
they're trying their best to to move to
a
nationalized health care system here i
know you guys are
yeah they're trying very very hard and i
i don't know how i feel about it but
i'll tell you this
if you do come to america with or
without insurance and you drink
or overdose on drugs the ambulance is
coming
and you will get you will get brought to
it and i will have to pay for it and you
will have to pay for it
and if you know what that means if you
don't
someone pays for it it's the same thing
if you don't
it's still going to be paid for so what
would happen
if i don't pay for it who's how how can
i not how can i get out of paying for
that how does somebody else pay
you you just don't pay you default on
the debt you would default on the debt
you'd take
that on personally whatever that looks
like but the price of the goods and
services in the system will go
up and that's why we have eight dollar
aspirin when you have surgery right we
know that it's not
this aspirin don't cost eight dollars
but it's just it's just
the bucks being passed to those who can
pay it whether you have insurance et
cetera i mean
right now in the united states we have
high deductible health care plans
where you're being made even though
you're paying insurance every month
you're being made to bear the
responsibility
of most of your routine routine care
whether it's some acute illness
your chronic or scheduled
appointments um you you pay for it
because you have these deductibles that
are
tens of thousands of dollars and that's
what it comes down to doesn't it it's
sort of like when that responsibility is
taken off you you behave badly
um and that's just sort of what happens
but like we said this all sort of comes
back down to crypto because it's all
about taking that personal
responsibility
so i want to just talk a little bit
about bitcoin actually so
you're buying a ridiculous amount every
single week so firstly
you clearly i know you obviously have
surplus cash to put into it
but you i feel like nobody in their
right mind would put that much money
into it if they didn't believe in it so
you think
firstly why do you firstly why are you
so bullish on bitcoin why do you believe
in it
yeah i mean this goes back five years or
so
when you know i started on my crypto
journey um
i'm very interested in infrastructure
investing so
that's why i built fast med it was
simply a
infrastructure play on the gap between a
primary care physician and an emergency
department
there were no after hours walk-in
options that were low-cost and high
quality so i built that out
when crypto uh was introduced to me
i was most interested in mining um and
again
right this is like 2015
2016. so we plugged in
gpu miners to a power plant i was
running
and you know just participated in the
the what what i think to be the
infrastructure around
crypto that led me to start to
understand exchanges
start to understand all coins i was
first introduced to ethereum
then it led me to look at bitcoin then i
got red pilled
read the white paper started to think
about the power of scarcity
the power of this decentralized system
that was being introduced the
the kind of network effect of
peer-to-peer money
and i i was sold on a use case of
bitcoin
just as uh a store of value a long time
ago i haven't been looking for
anything else for bitcoin i don't really
know
the store of value for me um
okay it's it's uh
it will become a unit of exchange for me
it's a store of value
i just hold it it's got tremendous
uh deflationary properties
that in just a short time you know i did
this and tweeted it
um recently if you go back to 2010
and you buy an extra large coffee at
dunkin donuts it's going to cost you a
dollar 63.
and in 2010 one bitcoin was 12 cents
so to buy that coffee it would cost you
13 bitcoin
right fast forward to today that same
extra large coffee
is like two dollars and sixty cents
right but it would cost you .00095
bitcoin
so you have inflation the cost of goods
and services going up
but you have this unbelievable expansion
of value in bitcoin over 10 years you
know you would have spent
13 bitcoin or 130 000
right on your coffee and today you're
paying a fraction of that in satoshi's
so you never i mean you never buy
anything with bitcoin
you know you may use some satoshi's to
do a transaction
but for me never spend a whole bitcoin
and if you have a lot of cash
right i have a uh a a portfolio
i would say a modern portfolio in terms
of its construction
it has real estate it's got stocks bonds
currencies commodities i just don't like
holding cash
i'd rather hold bitcoin yeah and i you
know i'm totally with you we've seen how
it's been the best appreciate
appreciating assets sorry in the last 10
years um you know i think it's
unbelievable
um but is it just a store of value
because i speak a lot um well the xrp
army speak a lot to me sort of tell me
you know it's
they say you know it it has no use case
it can't be used as a uh
i don't care about transaction i don't i
don't care about transaction speeds
i don't it's simple the best use case
uh for bitcoin is to hold it it is your
head
against okay information just hold it
okay so okay fine so
help me understand then why where does
its value come from right so
like would you say scarcity is the is
the one and only sort of answer to that
like
why is it going up why do you believe
that it is that
safe haven that store of value well it
has some
interesting mechanisms right like i'm
one that thinks that
the cost of computing and the
operational expense of running those
computers
establishes some of bitcoin's value then
you have
the having or the scarcity algorithms
that are built into it
and like the scarcity thing is
absolutely amazing if you really
step back what asset do you know
has provable scarcity like bitcoin has
well you i mean there's great question
is does gold have provable scarcity
silver have provable real estate
even land no bitcoin
to me like it's it's an amazing
uh function of its uh of its algorithm
okay cool so when new all-time highs
jason
october yeah well i mean i've said that
you know i believe that we'll get to a
new all-time high by october 31st or i
have to eat two filet of fish sandwiches
or something like that i think that's
okay that is like not even a penalty
whatsoever like
that's what donald's right mcdonald's is
great that's a terrible penalty
for me i don't even know what is inside
of fileta fish but uh
oh yeah apparently it's finished yeah
hopefully there's some fish but no
october october 31st of this year i
think
i think it's very achievable to have a
new all-time high and then from there
i think it's just going to be wild so
look there's no
i'm here sharing my experience whatever
um this is do your own research there is
no investment i can offer you
that i believe that i feel as compelled
to participate in than bitcoin
i mean i heard ralph paul say the same
thing recently like
um it is absolutely
the best investment you can participate
in right now against everything
okay so so explain to me what's going on
why
where so i did a tweet yesterday um and
i can't remember what it was it was
something like um
bitcoin oh i don't know it was something
like oh uh
bitcoin is sofia what i don't know like
uh blockbuster netflix was the
blockbuster or something like that
but a lot of people were just very angry
about that so why don't people believe
in it people that forget
like forget like non-coiners people
within our community
why are people so anti-bitcoin like what
is the problem and i don't want to hear
about ah they didn't get in they didn't
make that they
made that money so they're a little bit
salty no no like why
are they so angry about it because i can
tweet something about bitcoin something
positive
and i will get backlash so what's the
issue yeah
i don't i don't i don't get that unless
you're getting backlash from
like ethereum or or altcoins i mean is
that where the
point is got it yeah yeah so so that's
really it i mean look
the the people who are bitcoin
maximalists
are are absolutely trailblazers they are
so focused like everything else is a
scam
there's only bitcoin did you see what
happened did you see
did you see the drama you didn't see the
drama no i don't see it i don't see it
okay it was a house of drama the other
day
i tweeted something like could you
imagine like imagine hating someone
because they don't like the same coin as
you say out loud i can't stop laughing
like no lie i was just chilling laughing
so hard
like actually like imagine if you're
like super into ethereum and i'm like oh
no now i hate jason williams
so adam back replied something like
imagine
liking i don't know like charles ponzi
blah blah blah
and i was like oh well absolutely not
that didn't include criminals
so he then put charles ponzi and
um what was the other one charles ponzi
bernie made
off in the same sentence as xr he said
ripple instead of xrp
um and cardano and ethereum
so he basically just called them like
scams um straight up and i know
vitalik wasn't happy um dan is at
larimer wasn't happy
none of them were happy um so yeah
absolutely like
bitcoin maxis i said that you i said
that to you before look
i'm saying like 99
of all of my crypto investments like the
concentration of my money is in
bitcoin it's not even an adventure it's
in bitcoin
but i have like bitcoin maximalist like
saying i hope you get aids
like that's what somebody why because i
because jason i i know because i
interviewed
uh camila russo and we were talking
about defy
and i bought some link and was obviously
you should be buying link
right because i bought some link and uh
because i'm so
influential like i have all this reach
and power like i'm this powerful warlord
from the basement right that when i buy
link the whole world just
moves and sways how dare you
how dare you should be more responsible
jason
right so i and it's really people who i
actually have never met
but i i actually like like hottlenaught
the little the cat guy he's like dude
yeah like i have a picture of ronaldo
because i'm just joking like it's like
you have ronaldo dancing after i bought
3200 link
and i get dude and then i get i hope you
have an
immunodeficiency syndrome you know like
it's just bad it's not good and it
it actually affected me which nothing
ever really bothers me per se
but i was like man like i should be
allowed to be intellectually curious
on my own twitter feed and then make a
joke or
explore things that i think are
interesting like g5
like learn about aetherium like learn
about all coins
or even explore why is everyone
interested
in doge like that's okay
it's freedom of thought right and i
think what's hilarious about this
community
um is that we generally speaking
everyone's all about freedom
individuality let's get away from the
government
yet when it's within our community
there's
a sort of we shun people that do do
things differently we shun people that
have their own independent thought right
and i never understood that and you know
speaking about people sort of like
being absolutely a lot of scammer there
are a lot of scammers though and i think
that
the reflexivity of the bitcoin
maximalist to go everyone's a scammer
they're trying to protect people
from like a lot of i don't think it's
as um uh altruistic or
positive right but in my heart i'm
hoping that's the case like they're
saying
look bitcoin is it all the rest of this
is scams hex is a scam
ethereum's a scam you know everything is
a scam
yeah yeah i mean it's an it's an
interesting one but i think within this
community
um you know we talk a lot about
individuality and
um you know freedom freedom of thought
independence and so on but i often find
you know
when that happens we're not happy so for
example
um i think what got most attention for
me was my tick tocks that i did quite a
few months ago
and um those didn't go down very well
with a lot of people they sort of found
that it was which ones in particular
um oh they were all they were all pretty
similar just like a fun song and being
like
bitcoin this bitcoin that dude i don't
know safe haven and decentralize you
know
that didn't go over well why because
you're appreciated with
uh other projects no no because i'm
female and i look pretty
oh that's yeah absolutely and and i got
a lot of backlash and i got back i got i
got horrendous
i got horrendous backlash from a lot of
um anonymous accounts i've got somebody
that says
and i'll say this out loud it's kind of
rude or whatever but somebody that said
i bet she rides the 10 o'clock every
friday night
which is just disgusting and then i got
a lot of backlash from the women
um as well which was quite interesting
and i thought it was such a shame
because these are people that
preach individuality and freedom
and here's me being an individual and
it's not okay
uh i totally agree look you you should
do you
and um i i just
can't imagine projecting on you that you
need to be in a black turtleneck
to to do any any work of any type
of anything serious is it so silly it's
it's no but
beyond it being hot i just think it's
it's
it's ridiculous and look if if
your strengths are in your physical
attributes and you want to use those
to to uh tell a story whatever
everyone and and i thought this was an
area that you and i
would deviate on actually because i'm
probably
very financially conservative but more
socially liberal
and you don't strike me as being a very
person and you can get into that yeah
because i would think you were more like
a traditionalist
and i okay okay
shall i go or yeah please please yeah
yeah okay so so i am
somewhere very much in the middle and i
think people sort of
i i find that i actually i would say i'm
socially liberal
um because actually i'm a libertarian so
we have to understand what social
liberal
really means or what a libertarian
really means people are free to choose
their own sexuality people are free to
do what they want
i have an issue when we start
undermining science um
and when we i also have an issue when we
start allowing men um
biological men in women only safe spaces
um as a woman
i'm uncomfortable with the man in my
changing room that's just it i don't
want to you know
i don't think all men are bad i don't
think all trans people i don't think
anyone really is bad i just
i i understand there are threats out
there but here we are in north carolina
we don't have uh men's and women's
bathrooms any longer
yeah and and that would make me really
uncomfortable um
really if you go to starbucks they're
just unisex bathrooms
and i'm uncomfortable with that as a
female somebody who
like i'm strong in my heart and in my in
my mind
um i lift weights but i'm still not
physically as strong physically as a man
so i'm uncomfortable with that so
socially i am you know liberal you can
do what you want
um but let's not undermine science and
let's not sort of like change the
fabrics of society and of reality
um because you can go too far and wait
you know where do we draw the line
do people sort of you know when a 50
year old man can identify as a 14 year
old little girl
i mean that has dangers can a can a
a 12 year old boy identify as a 30 year
old man so we can go buy alcohol
there are issues we have to think like
issues and long-term sort of thing but i
am socially liberal like each to their
own you know
because i'm a libertarian um but we are
coming up to an hour
now go on go on yeah so what
i love yeah i love the tweet
that you made when you said bring
masculinity back
and masculinity yeah make men masculine
again
and then i ripped you off and said make
women feminine again
oh yeah let's make us feminine what is
wrong with that like that's
like i don't think there's anything
wrong with that and i also
don't think there's anything wrong with
a man being metrosexual a man being gay
a man being
but that's not attractive to me maybe
you know like and you in that case you
speak for most men let me tell you men
most men want a feminine woman and most
women want a masculine man and in my
opinion if it was gonna tell me that oh
yeah so but
but in my opinion if a woman says that
she doesn't want a masculine man i just
think she's lying to herself
i'm a strong independent female that can
absolutely handle herself
but i still want a masculine man i want
to switch off he can do it
yeah and and you should have the right
to express yourself
in any way you want as long as it
doesn't hurt me
right as long as it doesn't hurt me um
and i mean
should i pinch on anybody else like stop
me from something
you know i may be offended visually or
like
auditorially or with that's even a word
but
like otherwise like get on with it
like give me a break but i shouldn't be
able personally
to show up to a woman's soccer game and
like the way i look right now and say uh
look i'm trying out for the pro team
here in north carolina
you're going to call me jessica and then
i just
and i just start bashing everyone all
over the place yeah and we've seen how
there's been actual accidents
that have happened just because these um
because these trans women
are physically stronger than the men
we've seen that accidents have happened
we've seen unfair advantages um and you
know what's really hilarious about this
whole thing
is that you have a lot of feminists who
are very much anti the patriarchy
pushing for women but this is like the
patriarchy it's
bringing men into women's sports you're
taking away
like the woman's opportunity to get a
gold medal
i mean it's hilarious it's sort of so
counterproductive and that's what we're
seeing in society in general
everything is sort of taking up we you
know we're trying to do good
but as we move forward it's sort of
taking us back
30 40 50 years um but anyway
we are approaching an hour so jason give
us your last thoughts i'm gonna put you
on full screen i need to figure out how
the hell i do that so let's just oh
that's me full screen okay
oh now i've added you oh god how do i do
this oh i know i know
there you go you're full screen give us
your last thoughts jason yeah so
uh look we we've touched a lot of topics
here
i think uh what i would leave you with
is you can do anything
you can be anything i totally believe in
like manifesting
um your thoughts and your thoughts are
so important
um so make them good thoughts be around
great people
people who kind of inspire you who
stretch you
find mentors that that are where you
want to be
at that stage of your life and outgrow
them
and um and you can do anything i mean
i i i can't tell you uh how
uh fortunate uh i am and uh to have had
the uh
the help i've had along the way i'm not
where i wanna be
you know leia has been very kind and
called me a billionaire i'm not a
billionaire but i'm on my way but i'm on
my way
uh and um in the next three or four
years
uh check the stats for all you haters
for all the haters go get them jason
jason i eat
i need it i eat that hate yeah yeah oh
yeah you have to you have to use it as
your motivation um you know i get a lot
of hate online particularly from women
um they absolutely hate me it's very sad
i think i'm a very nice person i think i
probably get on with them quite well
anyway but um hey ho
just gotta keep going jason you've been
amazing i want to thank you so much for
those that didn't know i was super
nervous to do this
um and you've been so lovely so i want
to thank you so much
thank you to cakewallet our sponsors and
thank you to icon plus for powering this
so
over and out mwah see ya